bonjour maria conforti merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
quelles conséquences avant d'avoir cet
arrêté sur vos actions et sur les
migrants eux mêmes
alors d'abord on conteste cette cette
décision du tribunal d'administratif
donc on verra dans une quinzaine de
jours
quelle est la réponse deuxièmement bas
on est obligé de ruser avec le
gouvernement donc c'est ce sens
certaines rues et certains coins du
centre ville de calais où son boulot les
interdictions prennent place
donc on ruse et on distribue juste à
l'extérieur de ces zones interdites et
hier ça a marché donc on va voir si on
peut continuer et puis évidemment il
faut absolument qu'on trouve des
endroits on trouvera toujours des
endroits parce qu'il ya beaucoup de ya
peu près 300 réfugiés qui sont seulement
dans le centre-ville de calais en tout
ya peu près 1500 personnes à calais mais
300 dans le centre ville et ces
personnes n'ont pas accès à la
nourriture donc de toute façon on
trouvera en trouvera une façon de leur
distribuer de la nourriture
est ce que justement cet arrêté ne
l'at-il pas aggraver les conditions
sanitaires dans lesquelles vivent les
migrants à calais aggravé les conditions
sanitaires papa les conditions
sanitaires et les conditions turbie
les la situation des exilés est très
très difficile à calais ils sont chassés
sans arrêt de leur endroit de leur goal
endroits où ils tentent de survivre de
se poser est d'ailleurs la présence de
d'exilés à calais est entièrement une
conséquence d'une évacuation d'une zone
où il était au mois de juillet qui a été
complètement bouclée grillage et
couverte de barbelés et cetera donc ces
exilés ne peuvent plus aller là où il
était tout petit peu en dehors de la
ville donc ils se sont repliés sur le
centre de la vie donc cette décision
française
cette présence d'exilés dans le
centre-ville est complètement une
conséquence des décisions des autorités
vous le disiez tout à l'heure vous vous
tentez de faire en sorte de toujours
réaliser votre mission c'est à dire de
donner à manger aux migrants est ce
qu'en termes de justice vous avez prévu
quelques quelques recours de tout nuit
comme j'ai dit nous avons déjà déposé un
appel de cette décision de justice donc
on verra on verra ce qu'il en sort
et puis aussi on a organisé une manif on
organise une manifestation ce samedi
dans calais donc on se laisse pas
abattre
l'union européenne doit annoncer
aujourd'hui une réforme de la politique
migratoire est ce que vous attendez
quelque chose en particulier le
bruxelles à ce sujet on aimerait
évidemment la politique migratoire n'a
besoin d'être organisés au niveau
européen et pas seulement au niveau
français et toute l'europe a besoin de
se mettre d'accord et et et se mettre
d'accord et et apple pour avoir une
politique d'accueil plus que celle qui
existe en ce moment qui n'est pas une
politique d'accueil mais une politique
de non accueille quand on voit les clubs
français prévoient de renvoyer des des
personnes qui ont conquis divalto
le temps l'île de lesbos et dont le camp
a été brûlée qui lors des qui dit on va
les aider en les renvoyant chez eux
c'est catastrophique vous change plus
plusieurs associations le mois dernier
avec l art n l'onu sur les conditions de
vie des migrants à calais quelle est la
réalité aujourd'hui sur place comment
vivent les migrants ch vous écouter ses
1500 personnes à calais seulement qu'ils
vivent qui survivent sous un buisson
derrière un arbre dont i dont absolument
pas d'endroit où se mettre et mêmes
l'endroit où il se met est en fait
évacuer entre guillemets toutes les 48
heures au minimum
la police vient et leur dit de dégager
et il serait installé quelques heures
plus tard et c'est rebelote
quarante huit heures plus tard donc
c'est ça en permanence et c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui on a le premier
jour d'automne ici et on s'inquiète tout
le temps parce que ils vivent dans fin
quand il faut que j -ch dehors dans des
conditions comme ça c'est insupportable
je devais instant un plusieurs
associations à calais avait alerté l'onu
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez reçu des
réponses qu'est ce que vous attendez
exactement de l'onu on attend que que
les choses soient rendues de plus en
plus public et qu'on puisse arriver à ce
qu'on puisse arriver à faire des
changements c'est très difficile ça fait
six ans que je suis impliqué on voit la
situation s'empire est tout le temps
plutôt que s'améliorait mais mais on
peut pas on peut pas s'arrêter et de se
battre pour le droit le droit à avoir
une vie normale de toutes ces personnes
qui ont dû fuir leur pays parce que leur
situation était impossible
on ferait tous la même chose si on était
dans leur situation on irait voir
ailleurs
on irait
essayer de s'installer ailleurs donc c
est le droit d être du 1 d'aller dans un
endroit de pouvoir bouger et donc on
espère que l'onu va avoir un effet sur
la france sur l'europe et ses rabais
c'est un petit pas à la fois merci
beaucoup maya conforter d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur arte france rappelle
que vous êtes secrétaire général de
l'association l'auberge des migrants
merci beaucoup